[Music]
Josh and 28 year old baby tiger star asa
consol is our hot and heavy that's what
a source tells ET six months after he
and Fergie announced their split
we're told quote Josh met Ava and
February is head over heels for the
actress but he felt guilty that he had
feelings for another woman so quickly
and he wants to be respectful to her me
so he has kept this relationship very
very private
I'm very ride-or-die I have you if you
need me I'm there no matter what time
like I'm that girl I have not gotten
very lucky I'm gonna get Fame Emma but
you know what I'll get my ride-or-die
eventually so just who is Josh's new
girl she got her start until the
novellas and makes out with Justin
Timberlake in his supplies music video
ASA has been linked to other stars after
their high profile breakups in 2013 she
was snapped kissing Liam Hemsworth the
day after he and Miley announced their
split and in 2016 she was leaked with
Calvin Harris three months post t-swift
as for what Fergie banks will our source
tells us for he knew that Josh was ready
to move on